go go go go go go go bhaga bhaga bhaga
good evening i'm pop it's more iya the
new news anchor a few news our first
story comes from YouTube YouTube is
canceled that's right YouTube is fine
170 million dollars for collecting
children's personal data big oopsie very
large oopsie by YouTube they have to see
fine Google 136 million they are forced
to pay an additional 34 million to the
state of New York why I don't know
because they collect their children's
personal data this is actually an old
story that happened back in September
but now it looks like it's affecting
everyone
every single person on the platform it's
pretty nuts I didn't think it was a big
deal at first but the more I look into
it the more I realize this is actually a
huge deal
YouTube has previously said that it's
for 13 years and older if you sign up
for YouTube you can't do it unless
you're over 13 I don't know exactly how
it works but they have the kids app for
people younger than 13 because it's
illegal to collect personal data on kids
that's how YouTube gets their
advertising revenue that's how I make my
money because you get targeted ads based
on personal data which are obviously
much more worth than I don't know
normal ads I guess that's Google's whole
business model if you didn't know that
well I don't know what to tell you
so what the government of you would say
even though it's American base it still
applies the worldwide because obviously
YouTube is located in America America
has this government-run facility called
the FTC I don't know if this is correct
but they have this I don't know what
they call it an act called Coppa which
is Children's Online Privacy Protection
Act and it's to protect kids online
which makes sense you know I don't think
collecting kids data is good I don't
want that no one is arguing for that and
I think it's really confusing to me
because obviously YouTube has the kids
app so what's the issue I assume what
happened was that YouTube created kids
app and said okay well this is where all
the kids goes but then FTC comes back
and be like actually you know what kids
are still watching YouTube on you too
this is not enough and that's why they
got the fine but then again why is it
youtubes fault that your kid is going
online decision American take on things
it's never the parents fault it's always
someone else's fault
so now what every YouTube creator has to
do is they have to make a choice when
they upload a video saying what's this
video made specifically for kids or was
it not made specifically for kids and
YouTube uploaded this video to instruct
about you create content for YouTube
this video is very important to watch as
it describes changes to the upload
process all of your existing videos and
potentially your monetization so what
you have to do now so you have to go
into your advanced settings and you can
say no my videos isn't made for kids
epic okay fine that's almost a problem
right now YouTube knows in addition to
this setting will use machine learning
systems to help us find content that is
clearly made for kids that's cool
machine learning has always worked
really well in YouTube is this like the
opposite hahaha apocalypse before you
kiddin make edgy constant now you're not
allowed to make family-friendly content
it's so confusing well regardless you
know it seemed like the liability was on
YouTube YouTube is getting fine
mm-hmm-hmm Federal Trade Commission made
a statement and it's pretty shiny ology
that I think of is the expression about
shooting fish in a barrel
YouTube is the barrel and the content
creators are the fish did he just say
he's gonna shoot us there will be
consequences Jesus Christ this guy is
terrifying there will be consequence
what did I do we have a variety of tools
at our disposal to cull through those 23
million channels and in an expeditious
way so when we talk about what does that
mean we are typically talking about
civil penalties not only can we sue
Google and YouTube for compliance with
Coppa but also individual channel owners
and content creators cool so not only
can they sue YouTube they can sue people
that upload content online
why my what that makes no sense control
your children please so I think the
maximum that FCC can sue you for is
fifty forty two thousand that's what I
heard at least but that's per video
basis I have five thousand videos on my
channel if twenty four videos get deemed
by FTC is targeted for kids then I own
them one million dollars epic I forgot
to mention so what happens if a video
gets made flag made for kids the video
will not get recommended by other videos
most of the revenue will be a removed
from sixty to ninety percent of the
revenue is just caught off completely
and all the comments will be removed
from that video as well I mean when I
first heard about I was like oh well I
never purposely made content for kids I
never try and direct my content for kids
but then at the same time YouTube now
has changed their format so you can't
swear edgy content is really not allowed
so you're kind of forced to be
family-friendly but now it seems you're
getting punished for it you could
possibly get a lawsuit it's so crazy
and then first again at first my initial
reaction was like yeah you know what if
I understand FTC there's a lot of
clearly 100% clearly in my opinion
content that is made for kids on the
platform which is very profitable and
very very lucrative I mean you got
morgues I can't see anyone over the age
of 12 watching morgues and it's always
kind of weird like why is that on
YouTube why is that not on the kids app
isn't that what the kids have is for
right in case you didn't know this the
most profitable channel on YouTube is
Ryan's toy review which is a
seven-year-old unboxing toys that's
clearly made for kids okay no add up
that let that's an obvious case in my
opinion what the finding is we are
inside a PC Knights part he's passed out
in the back Regina what did you do I
didn't you got until Battle Royale with
a bunch of huggers and they did this to
him
I don't see anyone over the age to tell
watching this is either sorry chat but I
think he knows these are clearly made
for kids right and it always weirded me
out and even Jake Paul you know I
remember a nerd seated it did a really
good video on this where he showed just
how Jake Paul is marketing to kids all
these colored areas is him talking about
plug for different merchandise and
different products and touring this is
all promos for kids and Jake Paul
himself even said what his audience is
I'd say it's like eight years old to
like 16 years old and so that's why okay
ladies and gentlemen we got him a fake
now here's what he changed for me
because YouTube is already starting to
strike down on videos and and flagging
them as kit for kids only and by the way
what happens if the video gets flagged
for kids only or specifically made for
kids it means you get caught up from
recommended you're not allowed to read
the comments anymore and most of your
revenue is gonna go away probably
between sixty to ninety percent of your
revenue is gonna be gone
so it's hits a pretty significant change
it's hitting people that I don't think
deserve it like this channel for example
pixel ban his content was flagged by it
he does figurines he shows figurines old
toys it doesn't strike me as for kids at
all when I watched it but I guess since
his toys that makes it liable and that
shows kind of where the line is drawn on
he tweeted that his Watchmen figurine
was made for kids his South Park series
made for kids South Park's I was really
wrong I'm like oh so it's not for kids
no way it is they specified it for kids
obviously YouTube is gonna do wrong but
at the same time goddamn this really
shows and it's not just him there was
another figurine channel Jang bricks for
example who just like Lego builds adults
can enjoy this stuff I enjoy this stuff
it's like máximo fooders Pokemon a card
autoboxing he's clearly not made for
kids but it wouldn't surprise me if he
gets flying as well delightful who made
the point of why am I supposed to swear
now is that what's happening because I'm
doing four dull videos it again
sure may be kids watching but how is
that hurtful they're clearly not
directed to kids at least
not the vibe I got artistic preference
of course but I prefer exaggerated or
simplified characters faces -
realistically sculpted one so seeing
that is this it makes it very very very
annoying even cypher dentists well who's
done animation on my channel they are on
my channel
they got flat as made for kids what
because it's a cartoon because it's
animation think about all the animators
on YouTube now are they gonna like
YouTube
don't make edgy content also YouTube
don't make family-friendly content feels
like a joke at this point I think jack
is a good example too cuz I think people
have this idea that Jack is
family-friendly or because he plays
games or whatever but in reality he
swears a lot he drops a freaking C word
or is FTC gonna be able to see that
nuance and be like oh well he plays
minecraft so adults can enjoy kids games
it's not a kids game kids just like it
that's not my fault
me when I rewatched PewDiePie videos and
forgot he used to swear line yeah I
stopped swearing in my videos and since
it's my bread and butter if I upload it
once a month and had like a brand deal
yeah it wouldn't matter but I'm not
gonna lose revenue just to say [ __ ] it
just seems so stupid but now it's my
minecraft video who's gonna again I
don't understand another thing I have
figurine an unboxing collection I don't
think it's for kids but looking at how
YouTube is looking at these videos how
do you respond to that it feels like I'm
supposed to hit this is made for kids
even though I don't think it is and then
if FTC says oh by the way you flagged
this as for kids we're gonna sue you or
whatever I know this is a problem
improbable thing that will happen but
still it would make me legally liable
ISA if I flag it for kids right because
that's admitting guilt that's admitting
yo yeah no I think you're right when I
don't think it's right so I'm just
forced to remove this video instead
that's like the only thing I know how to
deal with this I love this to eat me
trying to make roblox videos for fun the
FTC stop right there criminal scum
nobody breaks the law and my watch I'm
confiscating your stolen goods now pay
your fine or it's off to jail there's
Ryan's tour review and then there's
people making content that kids maybe
enjoys what the hell are they supposed
to do about that it makes no sense and
it's only also saw this tweet honestly
the whole thing is backwards
access the common suggestion - a user
should be done on a per account basis
not her video basis yes thank you
there's so many channels on YouTube that
make really good family-friendly content
is that not a thing anymore and I think
it's one of these things where we just
gonna have to wait and see and and see
how FTC enforces this if you're a
smaller Channel I wouldn't I guess I
don't know I know one thing for sure is
for sure what's up my 19 year olds
that's right your 19 year old now
congratulations
dammit I can't believe it
they grow up so fast you can comment on
this proposition and leave your feedback
if you want to I love this by the way in
in their presentation as example slang
and pop-culture phrases such as fun free
stuff whatever cool duh duh you know I
use ironic family-friendly jokes in my
in my minecraft series like clip clop
and I say all this like childish work
words as a joke are they gonna be able
to tell that I don't know stop why is
YouTube air always like this always can
you imagine these channels that are
making like figurine or Lego or whatever
just like that livelihood ching chong
being bong you know what I mean not that
big
next news oh my god if I go on Twitter
this is what I see these anime avatar
kids are just absolutely relentlessly
calling me i trans folk on Twitter I
like this person with the most retweets
who then admitted no I didn't watch the
video epic so why am i transform well
because I allegedly purposely
misgendered someone it was in my dr.
Phil video Zoomer thinks his mom is too
irrelevant this video I got claim by the
way r.i.p i'm glad we went through all
this extensive effort to try and try and
get it monetize regardless this person
who to me so clearly was a jeffree star
wannabe or look-alike or inspired
whatever and I honestly I don't even
think about it because she had a
masculine name her name was Bama and and
I looked it up
BAM Aaron is a boy's name so he's not
that weird to think they would be
referred as a he
and she wasn't mentioned as she anywhere
by anyone in the video so it's not that
weird if I did I would have noticed and
I would have changed it but no I'm a
transfer okay
did you not know that I didn't watch the
video but PewDiePie is a transform I
know what his intent is at every point
you know I actually support LGBT I would
never and I could have been more careful
but I would never purposely misgender
someone as a way to antagonize her troll
like but I wouldn't do that same with
sexuality that's not that's not okay you
shouldn't do it either I wouldn't do it
but these dumbass
anime avatar kids on Twitter I mean your
brains are not fully developed clearly
you're just making noise you're not
helping anyone just wait for everyone to
respond now oh well you should be more
responsible yeah maybe you didn't do it
on purpose but it should wait it's the
same [ __ ] all over again go [ __ ]
yourself that's it
alright that was my de beauté Popish
Moria here hope you guys enjoyed pew
news I think I have a long prosperous
future as a news anchor I know I said I
wouldn't do pew news but I think if
topics interests me and it's worth
talking about like hop I think is really
important
I'll probably do these from time to time
okay epoch other than that thanks for
watching
if you want to support the channel
please buy merch please oh god